so Ruby yes sir Ruby yes okay okay Ruby
yes Ruby we're different where you grow
uh Orange County California yeah I'm
gonna put both my parents um one was a
foster and whoa mr. Bailey so doc foster
um my dad what married my mom so my
search Aggies yes how was it Charlotte
excellent yes we're gonna keep your high
school and high school I played sports
look and uh I did a lot of academics I
graduated six months earlier for my
classes you're good dude yes and then
we're where'd you live go after school
after school um I have friends and they
took me to a whole nother place I met
the spaceship man we're home the
spaceship and my dad he's mixed came off
so uh yeah he brought me a lot of
winters a lot of wonders in the world
where after high school um I went to
Apple Valley California after high
school we stayed probably about five
years after that and then I was from
Westminster California and my grandma
she knew the people that will know all
the Edwards theaters so I'd be over
there too I'm in Newport Beach LA
so that's so the doesn't she plays that
grew
and I'm calling the diner here Oh about
two months three months
right now I'm it's just saving the world
right now yes sir
I mean opening keys that I never knew I
had the ability to but when I had the
ability and card cube that caters and I
started doing and special intelligence
and I'm a family a federal judge as well
with your drug uh I do whatever
everybody else does yeah well that's
just whatever I don't do you heroin no
sir
and what do you do for money
um well my husband collects our welfare
check no no no welfare my my I lived in
the hospital when I was a child all my
life I stayed in st. Joseph's Hospital
Chuck Children's Hospital of Orange a
lot yes I was my family didn't come in
and out but I was like five years old
and I was obviously living in the
hospital
públicas had asthma chronic chronic
asthma where I almost died like two
times
yes realize all the time I was in the
living to the hospital so I'd be in and
out of school was raised was real good
family so that I'm example Valley
California and I married my divorced my
husband legally separated because he's
very abusive he asleep cheating on me
with other women downstairs so I had to
get rid of him and so then I lived with
my mother in the backyard well one day
the police they came they arrested me
for drawing a plunk in it right yeah
and my second and my mother was very
sick she or her mouth was open they said
she had cancer well now that I found out
my Azores got put in heroin he's pumping
heroin in to keep her sedated but I
didn't know this that time and when I
left there they said my mother was calm
there's she a duck I don't believe that
because I seen her after that in a
u-haul truck about a year and a half ago
and uh my children they went into foster
care have five an OD reason yes as much
as I did we were there were five my
other one was of age and I have it there
general right so
they told me that she died
and she did so I believe that the people
of America are taking care of her
underground because I left a lot of
people underneath these these floors
I've probably already let over a
trillion people up putz a second where
do you sleep at night
I sleep out just anywhere just on the
street yes sir huh no tannery
I'm sorry no tent um no I sleep in
different kids stuff just whatever
happens have you ever been treated for
no I live a very hard life but I'm the
charge I'm the target your target yes of
rat playing games snake thing games
spaceship monsters stuff like that but
I'm okay in my life thanks to Jesus
Christ is there one particular drug that
you um it doesn't matter if I do I'm
clear Mike I understand what's going on
I fill it I live in everything all right
Ruby thank you for talking to me
thank you brother yes sir god bless you
thank you
you